and Tim said I don't want you to plank
anymore with so many references and
Easter eggs we're willing to bet that
you haven't figured out all the
mysteries on this show these are 10
secrets that you didn't know about
Wednesday like did you know that Jenna
Ortega choreographed her own dancing for
episode 40 Wednesday yeah that same
dance that would later go viral being
recreated by artists like Lady Gaga and
how did Jenna prepare for it I watch
videos of goth clubs in the 80s I
watched Susie and the Banshees because
she was a reference maid Jenna took
heavy influence from the Susie and the
Banshees music video fun house I feel
kind of bad because I kind of I ripped
off a couple of her moves Jenna
unknowingly had covid while filming the
scene which made her a little surprised
to see it blow up online it was awful to
film and I asked to redo it but we
didn't have time apparently she woke up
feeling sick and they had to keep giving
her medicine between takes on set much
like with the choreography Jenna was
entirely new to the cello before being
cast and despite this she began training
with the instrument roughly two months
before filming began so that she could
actually perform her cello covers of
songs like the Rolling Stones Paint It
Black two months may not seem like a
whole lot of time to completely Master a
new instrument but at least it's more
time than she was given to learn German
I had just started dropping lessons that
week this may have been part of the
reason why many have pointed out her
strong American accent and flubbed
pronunciation of German words
while building the character of
Wednesday you might think Jenna would
have asked her predecessor Christina
Ricci a few questions after all she was
right there on set playing the role of
Miss Thornhill is there something I can
help you find a role that actually
almost went to actress Thora Birch of
Hocus Pocus Fame that is until she
dropped out over creative differences
but when Christina was brought on
instead she didn't want to be too too
overbearing on Jenna's performance while
Jenna didn't want to just copy
Christina's take on the character from
the 90s because of this we never talked
about her being Wednesday once but that
doesn't mean the two stars avoided each
other completely in fact they got along
famously Jeddah I love she reminds me of
how I was when I was younger and
Christina said it best I really feel
like every generation that meets there
on Wednesday and part of updating
Wednesday for a new generation meant
giving her a whole new look the costume
designer Colleen Atwood intended for
Wednesday's school uniform to serve as a
nod to her original dress but she also
wanted to include a gray and black
stripe and so she had Wednesday's
costume hand-painted before silk
screening the stripes giving them a
softer look in the end and when it came
to Wednesday's iconic braids Tim Burton
played around with a few ideas like
giving her silver streaks but Jenna
ultimately offered to have her hair
actually cut into a fringe maybe just
cut my actual hair and like Tim loved
this look so much that it became a
permanent part of the character but
Wednesday's costumes weren't the only
ones to get a bit of special attention
on set when it came to styling Gwendolyn
Christie as the mysterious principal
Larissa Weems I think Contrition might
be an order right now miss Adams Colleen
Atwood brought in a vintage poster of
Tippy hedron from the birds and she told
Gwendolyn this is who I think you are
and like Gwendolyn absolutely loved the
idea I wanted to subvert this idea of
the Hitchcock heroine she felt that she
wasn't exactly the sort of actress who
would have been cast in a Hitchcock
movie but wanted to explore what she
would look like if she was the character
that Colleen had the most fun styling
would actually have to be Wednesday's
roommate Enid though who's a super
bright color palette of Pinks and
oranges made her a sunny contrast to
Wednesday in Colleen's mind there is
definitely a reason why nobody would
describe Wednesday as funny still it
would seem that Tim Burton really lucked
out when he found Jenna Ortega for the
role had been compared to her my entire
life Jenna remembers being a pretty
weird child before going on to explain
that she's naturally very dry and
sarcastic and if you need further proof
that she's perfect for the role Jenna
had only just finished filming for the
horror film X when she first met Tim
Burton for her audition and so at the
time she was actually covered in stage
blood and glycerin sweat I got on the
zoom and he actually left maybe it just
gave him inspiration for the show's
sprinkler shower scene but then again
Tim definitely had a lot of time to
consider who he'd have as his perfect
Wednesday did you know this was actually
Tim's third attempt to try and get an
Adams Family project off the ground yeah
back in 1991 Tim was actually considered
as the director for the first Adams
Family film but he had to turn it down
to focus on making Batman Returns then
again in 22 10 he was approached by
Universal to work on a stop-motion
animation version of The Adams Family
but the project just never seemed to
work out The Adams Family is clearly a
personal story to Tim for a reason I
think that he sees a lot of himself in
Wednesday and because of this he had
some pretty unique insights into the
character such as suggesting that Jenna
never blink on set so Tim Burton's
UniQue Ideas didn't stop at asking Jenna
Ortega not to Blink he also insisted
that thing be played by an actual actor
and so he brought in magician Victor
dorobantu to play the part Victor was
dressed almost entirely in a blue suit
so that his body could be edited out and
not only that but the set actually had
to be built in such a way that would
allow him to move without being too
visible such as man shaped holes in
mattresses so that he could lay down and
kind of do his thing and the production
designer Mark scrutin compared it to
building sets for the Muppets stating
that the set had many trap doors and
secret ways of getting the actors in and
while Jenna Ortega was able to accept
the weirdness at the time it was really
odd actually looking back honestly we
were kind of wondering how they made
that work but speaking of the set did
you catch all the Easter eggs just sort
of hanging around in the background if
you look closely at the back wall of the
Weathervane Cafe you may just notice
pictures from Tim Burton's previous
movies there are also plenty of nods
made to the original Adams Family TV
show of course like the fact that the
nightshades code is a double snap Enid
and Wednesday also share a dorm in
Ophelia Hall which is a reference to
morticia's sister from the show
principal Larissa Weems gets her name
from Miss Weems the family's babysitter
from the show and the stuffed bear that
she keeps in her office is meant as a
reference to the stuffed bear the family
kept in the 60s but Easter eggs aren't
the only thing to look out for amongst
the set suppose every artist needs a
muse how much attention were you paying
to the Gargoyles at Nevermore Academy
there are quite a few of them but the
ones in the school's quad are meant to
represent the different types of
Supernatural students in attendance
there mark scrutin the production
designer teased that there's even a clue
to the mystery hidden way up there not
only that but the gargoyle's faces were
sculpted in such a way that their
expressions were actually able to change
depending on the mood of the scene and
like Mark even designed the Castle's
arches so that they looked like demonic
faces casting the stonework directly
from the castle they were filming out of
so that everything looked natural
Nevermore Academy was actually built out
of a castle in Romania a setting that
definitely lends to the show's Eerie
tone which of these well-kept secrets
were you most surprised by and like did
you notice anything that we might missed
we love a good mystery so make sure to
keep the guesses going in the comment
section down below with so many
references and Easter eggs there's no
way that you've managed to solve all of
the Mysteries on the Netflix series
Wednesday
[Music]